بالنسبة للملايين من الأشجار الاحتفالية المزينة ،
تلعب دورًا حاسمًا في هرجاء عطلتهم ،
لكن في لويزيانا
، استخدم جهد بيئي طويل الأمد الأشجار التي
تلعب دورًا حاسمًا في إعادة بناء
موطن ساحلي لأكثر من 20
عامًا في مدينة نيو أورلينز
والحرس الوطني لويزيانا و  دخلت إدارة الحياة البرية والثروة السمكية في الولاية في
شراكة
لجمع آلاف الأشجار بعد
الإجازات واستخدامها لإعادة بناء
المستنقعات الساحلية المتضائلة ، حيث
تستخدم المروحيات الجوية المسماة عملية إسقاط الشجرة
مروحيات الحرس الوطني
لربط المستنقعات المتآكلة بالأشجار الميتة
التي تعمل على اصطياد الرواسب والحفاظ عليها.
خلق المزيد من الأراضي والبيئات المستقرة
للحياة البرية ،
يقول الحرس الوطني في لويزيانا إن جهود
إعادة التدوير أعادت توجيه آلاف
الأشجار وساعدت في إعادة إنشاء مئات
الأفدنة من الأراضي الرطبة المهددة بالانقراض ، فلماذا
تركل شجرة عطلتك إلى الرصيف إذا كان من
الممكن استخدامها للمساعدة في كبح جماح
مشكلة بيئية
أجنبية